Former President
Donald Trump
is facing a new test of his 2024
presidential campaign
on the eve of his remarks
to an influential conservative group.
Some of Trump's competitors
made their appeals today.
CNN's Jeff Zeleny has more on C-PAC
and the Republican divisions
on display there.
It's long been a command performance
for Republicans
harboring White House ambitions.
It's great to be back at C-PAC,
but at the annual Conservative
Political Action Conference
outside Washington,
the parade of potential presidential
hopefuls is far shorter this year.
Former South Carolina
Governor Nikki Haley.
If you're tired and losing
puts your trust in a new generation,
and if you want to win,
not just as a party, but as a country,
then stand with me.
And former
Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo
gently called for a new direction
We shouldn't look for larger than life
personalities, but rather
we should find power in the rooms
like this one.
But the long running,
three day gathering called CPAC
is now seen as the Trump show.
These are my people. This is beautiful.
The former president is set to appear
Saturday,
joining a sea of loyal supporters
and members of his own family.
Your president, President
Donald Trump, will be here
who are rallying to return him to office.
But other big name contenders
who many Republicans see
as the party's future had other plans
Last year,
Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis took to the stage
as a rising star, CPAC.
But as he inched closer
to declaring a presidential bid,
he attended a gathering of donors
in Florida
hosted by Club for Growth,
an anti-tax group
urging the party to move on from Trump.
Several potential rivals
also skipped C-PAC and headed to Florida,
including former Vice President
Mike Pence.
South Carolina Senator Tim Scott.
South Dakota Governor Kristi Noem.
And New Hampshire Governor Chris Sununu.
And but admiration for Trump
was on full display at CPAC,
where Eddie
Phillips took a seat at a replica
Resolute desk
against a backdrop of a faux Oval Office.
Trump first. Okay.
And then DeSantis let's do that in 2018.
Colleen
Hoffman is from Jacksonville, Florida.
She wore a DeSantis hat
even as she sported a Trump sticker.
She said she's torn but believes
Trump is the stronger choice for 2024.
I really love this hat because it's like,
leave us alone.
You know, it's I love it.
But as of right now, I'm
looking for downtown
at the early stage of the campaign.
It's hardly a two man contest.
As Vivek Ramaswamy, an Ohio
businessman who jumped into the race
last month, made clear on the CPAC stage
when we rallied
behind the cry
to make America Great again,
we did not just hunger for a single man
We hungered for the unapologetic pursuit
of excellence.
That is what it means to be an American.
Yet even as the Republican field
grows, the conversations at CPAC
and the comparisons between candidates
always came back to Trump.
I think Governor DeSantis is wonderful.
I think he's amazing.
I just don't think it's his time
quite yet.
I think if he could just give it
four years,
I think he'd be a great
successor to Trump.
So in the middle of all
the celebration of the former
President Donald Trump,
these gentle calls
to turn to
a new generation are not met
with a lot of applause here
today, Brianna.
Clearly,
there is a respect for these candidates,
but there is a love for Donald Trump.
So when he arrives here
tomorrow, the question what does he do?
Does he start distinguishing himself
from some of his rivals?
His aides say count on it.
Yeah, it's going to be tough.
This really shows us the divide there.
Jeff, stay with us, if you would.
I want to bring in CNN's
Audie Cornish to the conversation.
Audie, I mean, we look at C-PAC.
How much does
this illustrate
the challenge ahead
for any possible Trump challenger?
Well, I think as CPAC
has become a home for more
and more kind of right wing voices
and at this point is
sort of fully ideologically captured
by the sort of Trump
family and Trump politics.
This is where you do
kind of have a testing ground
for these messages.
I don't think it's an accident
that Nikki
Haley is there trying out her argument.
Unfortunately, her argument
to a roomful of people is
that Republicans have been losing
and now it's time to be a winner.
I mean, you don't say that
to a bunch of people
who probably believe
President Trump's kind of election lies.
So there's still this
kind of it's not clear what
that message is.
If you are an alternative
to Trump,
how to make that message
safely to his base of supporters.
Yeah.
And Jeff,
you're talking to voters here at CPAC.
What are they saying to you?
Should be required to take a medal.
Well, this is a sea of true believers.
I mean, the merchandise on display every
type of Trump.
45 of course
he was the 45th president trying to be
the 47th is on display.
So this is
this is his crowd
but if you talk
a little bit deeper to them,
there is a sense of,
you know, is he the future of the party?
That, of course, is his burden to show
that he can be
the future of the party as well.
But one thing that is so different
at this is CPAC
and we've covered
so many of them is
when there's a Democrat
in the White House,
this is the year,
the year
before the presidential election
that is supposed to be
the testing ground
the proving ground
for Republican candidates
to talk about conservative policies,
conservative ideas,
much less
talk about conservative policies,
the debt
and other things
then a cult of personality
around the former president.
That's why this event is so different.
Certainly is not the harbinger of
of what's to come in the broader
sense of the Republican primary.
This is just one sort of stop along
the way. The actual
in a real
Republican voters and others out
there will certainly make this decision
But this is a essentially a Trump
rally spread over three days in a hotel
here just outside Washington.
So not necessarily
a broader sample
of what some Republicans are looking for.
Yeah, Audie.
And you make such a good point, Audie,
when you say that
Nikki Haley is saying
to a group of people
who may think that Trump won,
hey, if you're tired of losing,
they don't think that
he lost necessarily,
but she still has to convince them
that she can win.
And I wonder
if she has a winning lane here
considering this divide.
And another question is,
how many other people
are going to be in that lane?
I mean, technically, Mike
Pompeo would be in that lane.
Even the former vice
president Pence would be in that lane.
The alternative to Trump Lane
that maybe
is still kind of aligned or connected to
what would be considered
kind of establishment Republican values
or people
who are making the argument
that they could perform
much better in a general election.
I think that's still a hard sell
in these early days.
However, I want to add one other thing.
The fact that so many other potentials
are sort
of courting the donors,
courting the Club for Growth crowd
means that they do see some sort
of other path
for support within the party.
And it will be interesting to see
who comes out of that money race,
so to speak.
In a couple of months.
Yeah, it's a crowded field, Jeff.
It's very crowded.
It will be is our expectation.
It
It is.
And of
course, every
new face,
the larger the field,
the more it
benefits the former president.
No doubt about it.
That's how he came to win the nomination
back in 2016
after that very large 2015 primary fund.
So that
actually is the bigger point here.
The donor event down in Florida
some donors are trying to get behind
Governor Santos or others
trying to keep this field small.
That is going to be the thing
to keep an eye on that
we'll be talking about
for the days to come.
How many candidates
will be on that debate stage
in August at the first Republican debate.
A crowded field
certainly benefits the former president.
Sure does.
Jeff and Audie, thank you so much.
And be sure to catch Audi's
podcast, the assignment
with Audie Cornish,
available wherever you get your podcasts.